if i want a job interview i can't dress
like i want a dress i gotta get a suit
so the same thing in your mind if you
want better you can't use old keys to
open new doors
antoine at one point in your life you
were homeless yes i was okay and at
another point in your life you were
making six figures plus a year yes i was
okay maybe you can take us through
both times in your life and how they
intersected that was great couple first
questions i like it oh good okay um
homeless i came from humble beginnings
raised in south side jamaica queens and
has the best mom and his best dad
when you're younger you get mad at them
but when you get old you realize that
they're trying their best and it was
broken they're going through their own
internal demons
so around 20 that's around 20 um
i basically left the house
because at the time my mom
she's not here no more she chose her
boyfriend over her kids
so i left the house i was homeless for
like a year and a half
and i started a job
working in new york
and
that was a moment that i realized that
you got to do better
you can't let your past determine your
future and you got to your pain and
purpose
so i want you all that trials and
tribulations working myself work on my
trauma to help myself get myself better
and now today i'm just amazing man
um i was working in new york in the
hotel industry making six figures a year
but everybody live in new york know that
six figures a year is nothing
and i wasn't happy
and some of my friends like you make six
figures you have a good job what are you
doing
money don't bring happiness internally
i had a battle that i could do more in
life
so
i use my job
i basically used my job as my passion
to fund my dreams
so i didn't want to do the whole
freelance working in the film industry i
didn't want to do that because
i feel like i had a job
so i tell everybody you need a job and a
dream i let my job be my investor
to help me find my company answer while
in films and um the best this is ever
made
okay do you mind if we go back to when
you were 20 for a little while okay and
forgive me if i get too personal and no
you don't have to transfer okay okay um
and i we appreciate that and um i know
that's asking a lot
to go okay well
for me yeah okay um
so when you were when you were 20 and
you decided to leave and you saw okay
this is this is what my life is and and
i need to do what i need to do for
myself um did you have an idea about
making films at that time or you were
just looking at survival if someone told
me i'd be doing what i'm doing now i'll
laugh in the face because when you come
from the inner city especially where i
came from jamaica queens you know
survival mode so today i was trying to
get a job not go to jail not getting
murdered it's like around that time my
friends went to jail got murdered or
just went somewhere else that i want to
go so i was a survival mode um i didn't
start getting into the film business
probably around
28 29 seriously because from there i was
in the music business i was managing
artists directing music videos but when
you deal with hip-hop artists especially
in the inner city
a lot of them was going to jail getting
caught up so if you're a manager if they
stop your career stopped so from there i
said no i'm not reaching my full
potential
so i just started doing music videos
when music videos was the same thing
i had a big imagination
but at the time working with the artist
they didn't have the budget
so i was let me do a short film
i did my first short film called split
decision it was a female boxing film i
funded myself working my regular
nine-to-five job and it's let me invest
in myself because coming from the film
business when the big record labels
say no
that the rappers and the producers were
selling out the trunk on the on a treat
because we didn't wait for big major
labels we validated ourselves that's why
i got it the whole validates yourself
from the music industry because that's
where you came from and once i did my
short film i was like wow i did this
and they won so many awards and i was
happy and i said this is what i want to
do tell my stories use my imaginations i
don't need a degree i don't need a lot
of money i just need to execute and
that's yeah that's what happened
so you were working in the hotel
industry like hospitality yeah i was
doing that and i was on security okay
and um do you remember when you gave
your two weeks notice because you were
going from that to the music industry
yes no i'm still working
so
do my whole career i always had a job
because i ain't going to do freelance so
i work security and retail
i did private investigation if you think
your husband or wife is cheating i did
that and i almost became a cop but i
didn't do it but the whole time i had a
job because i hate relying
on another person to give me money and
do the whole fee like the freelancings i
didn't like it so i i worked my nine to
five job
doing my nine to five job after my work
i did my 24 hours in a day a lot of
times people say we don't have time you
have time you've got to make time
prior towards your time
so when you were dealing with hip-hop
artists
were you able to see some of the um
the life situations that were maybe
pulling them down yeah that you
remembered
and how were you able to maybe
either you didn't try to help them you
stayed out of the way because it was a
business relationship or it crossed over
because it was the whole package yeah i
try to help because i was doing my own
trauma myself i was trying to help but
you know it's just like you have friends
and family only so much you could do
they got to help themselves
so i was working on myself getting
better but they were still stuck
and i could have helped them because
like i said i wasn't rich i had
millionaire a lot of times in the in the
city
we don't do financial racism whole bunch
of stuff so
i couldn't help and a lot of the guys
that i was working with you know some of
them went to jail and some of them i had
them all did you see a lot of very
talented people very talented burn out
and not be able to i tell people at
times
coming from a drug area and you see a
lot of drug dealers it's tons of bill
gates and tons of steve jobs but they
have the opportunity
so
if you could hustle a neighborhood and
make all this money you can run a
company it's the same thing it's just
different product
but they didn't have the opportunities
so that's why for me
i decided that i don't want to go down
the route i want to go another route
and i chose let me just stay this path
let me get this nine to five jobs and we
do all the in our job and eventually
we'll work out
what's it like to lose everything it's
just humbling
and um
at first
you get sad you get depressed
but then the old you get you realize
that
you don't know what you had because you
never had that in the beginning
so that's what that's so it was i didn't
feel like i had anything i was just
surviving
and what changed
uh i had to reprogram myself um when you
coming from that environment
um you don't know if you're poor because
everybody's around you poor so you think
it's normal but once i realized i wanted
more out of life that's when the light
bug
so my security job i was working with i
usually work in the neighborhood but
then i start getting contracts in
manhattan and manhattan is a melting pot
you see different things that's why i
tell everybody take your kids
they can explore the world
because when i was growing up all i knew
was up the block you know at the block i
didn't go out the block there was so
much damage going up the block but once
i started working in my hand my eyes are
opening i start meeting different people
seeing that people into the tax brackets
i was like wow this is a better life out
there
and like anything a lot of times we
don't upgrade our mind we all grab our
clothes we all grab a phone but we don't
upgrade our mentor so when i start
reprogramming myself and one more on my
life that's when things start changing
and i start healing my pain and my
trauma because when you heal you see
different you spell diff you react
different
um and that's where the start is i
wanted more out of life
so do you think the the old antoine
could have been
making these films and and producing
them and bringing a team together no he
he's probably in jail right now
why
because when you have no foundation
so a lot a lot of times you see those
kids in the news and do bad things get
locked up
we're so quick to judge people but we
don't know their story a lot of kids
there's no other way i mean now
different now you have no excuses too
many options right now but back then in
the early 2000s
especially early 90s i grew up in 80 i'm
born in 81 i'm 40 now but it's no
options so sometimes we quickly judge
people with a situation a lot of times
it's the home environment so if the
foundation is broke
you don't know what so when i see kids
now they got both parents got everything
and they still i think that's
something's wrong that's that's that's a
whole different situation right there
but um but yeah just you know that
person would never so sometimes you got
to kill the old you that had to be the
person you want to be
how do you reprogram your mind it's hard
um but you got to do it so
i think the first time where was is i
had a few of my friends pass and go to
jail and i was asking myself like what
how can i get out of this like what
could i do to make things better and i
kept it simple
if i want a job interview i can't dress
like i wanna dress i gotta get a
suit so the same thing in your mind if
you want better you can't use old keys
to open new doors
you gotta start thinking different you
guys are loving yourself more a lot of
times we settle for less we do ninety
percent
we give to everybody else and we get the
crumbs so i had to reverse that
love myself more do more for myself and
i do less for everybody else
a lot of times we help help everybody
else and we left with nothing
so i tell people how to balance if
you're an actor
if you want to spend 90 percent in the
casting room
you're basically giving it an individual
control over your whole life split it up
could start writing your own films start
producing your own films and like give
your life a balance like a lot of times
we give good gifts and we don't give
nothing to ourselves
and so with the reprogramming do you
ever feel sometimes the old mindset
creeping back in no i killed that person
no
i don't want to go back
because that old mindset was
i was broken
and i had no one to talk to
and i didn't have a great family because
it was broken the blinding the blind so
no that person never come back i use
that old person as motivation to go
forward
you